He's eighteen. He grew up near San Francisco, playing football and video games. Hyder Akbar is his name. His family's from Afghanistan. And after the Taliban were defeated in 2001, his father's old friend, Hamid Karzai, now the president of Afghanistan, asked his dad to come back and help out. His dad and his uncles had all been part of the resistance that had kicked out the Soviets from Afghanistan, back in the 1980s.
他今年十八岁，在旧金山附近长大，喜欢踢足球和玩电子游戏。他的名字叫海德尔·阿克巴尔，家人来自阿富汗。2001年塔利班政权倒台后，他父亲的多年好友——现任阿富汗总统哈米德·卡尔扎伊，请求他父亲回国帮忙。在20世纪80年代，他父亲和几位叔叔都曾参加过将苏联势力赶出阿富汗的抵抗运动。
So, when Hyder was 17, he went to Afghanistan. This place that he'd been hearing about his whole life. And he took a tape recorder with him. You may have heard the audio diary that he put together for our radio show, with producer Susan Burton, about a year ago. Then the next summer he went back.
所以，在海德尔17岁那年，他去了阿富汗，去了这个他听说了整整一辈子的国家。他随身带了一个录音机。大约一年前，他为我们的电台节目和制片人苏珊·伯顿制作了一份音频日记，你可能听过。第二年夏天，他又回去了。
His father was now the governor of Kunar province, which is this remote area along the border with Pakistan. One of those contested areas where the Taliban and Al-Qaida and local warlords are all still fighting with the new Afghan government and the United States military. The fate of Afghanistan, we're sometimes told, is being decided in places like Kunar.
当时他父亲已是库纳尔省的省长，那是巴基斯坦边境附近的一个偏远地区。那里是塔利班、基地组织和当地军阀与阿富汗新政府及美国军队持续交火的冲突地带之一。人们常说，阿富汗的命运往往就在库纳尔这样的地方决定。
And in Kunar, Hyder saw amazing things. Things that reporters almost never get to see. He traveled with the US military. He saw them interact with the Afghans. He translated for them sometimes. He saw behind the scenes in the new government. Today on our radio show, Teenage Embed. WBEZ Chicago, this is This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. This is really one of the most special hours we have ever put together on the radio. And it is with pleasure that I turn things over to Hyder Akbar.
在库纳尔，海德尔看到了许多令人惊叹的事情，那是记者几乎无缘得见的景象。他随美军一同行动，观察他们与阿富汗人的互动，有时还为他们做翻译。他目睹了新政府幕后的点点滴滴。今天我们的电台节目主题是《随军少年》。这里是WBEZ芝加哥电台，节目是《美国生活》，由国际公共广播电台发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。这是我们在广播中制作的最特别的一期节目之一，我很高兴能把话筒交给海德尔·阿克巴尔。
I was met at the airport by Sartore, who is our driver. But he's almost become part of the family, because he's been with us for so long.
我们的司机萨托雷在机场接我。因为他跟我们共事了很长时间，他几乎成了我们家的一员。
Sartore! Sartore!
萨托雷！萨托雷！
And Sartore was my very good friend last summer. He was the person that was closest to my age. So we became really close.
去年夏天，萨托雷是我非常要好的朋友。他是和我年龄最相近的人，所以我们变得非常亲近。
[CAR HORN BEEPING]
[汽车喇叭鸣笛声]
Kabul has changed tremendously. Right now, there's like three girls in front of me. All they have is like a loose chador, but I see their jeans underneath their [? cloak. ?] Last year, burkas were probably about 95%. This year, I'd say they've dropped to under a quarter, one out of four.
喀布尔发生了翻天覆地的变化。此刻，我面前有三个女孩。她们只穿了件宽松的罩袍，但我能看到罩袍下她们穿的牛仔裤。去年，穿布卡长袍的女性大概占95%。今年，我认为这个比例已经降到了四分之一以下。
Apparently there's a new game show in Kabul. It's like a trivia show, asking like geographical questions, et cetera. You can hear it. I guess the trivia part's over, now they have a Coke drinking contest. Whoever can drink the most Coke, whoever finishes a one and a half liter bottle of Coke I guess wins.
看来喀布尔有了新的游戏节目。那是一个知识竞赛，问一些地理常识之类的问题。你能听到背景声。我想问答环节结束了，现在是喝可乐比赛。谁喝得最多，或者谁先喝完一瓶1.5升的可乐，谁就赢了。
OK, it starts. But the funniest thing is the prizes. They're like, six containers of oil. That's one of the prizes. Two cases of soap was another prize. One of the guys gave up. That guy won a box of detergent. The one who won the Coke drinking contest won a box of detergent, and some shoes.
好了，开始了。最逗的是奖品。其中一份奖品是六桶油。另一份奖品是两箱肥皂。其中一个人放弃了。那个人赢得了一盒洗涤剂。赢得喝可乐比赛的人赢得了一盒洗涤剂和一些鞋子。
Hello, hello. The road to Kunar is really bad. Sartore says, you can't really get a sense of the road unless you come and drive on it yourself. Hearing it on the microphone doesn't cut it. We're probably about three, four hours away from Kunar. We're going about 20 kilometers an hour, so 15 miles an hour, I'd say. We can't go any faster than that on these roads.
喂，喂。去库纳尔的路太糟糕了。萨托雷说，如果你不亲自开车走一趟，是无法体会这条路到底有多烂的。听录音是没用的。我们离库纳尔大概还有三四个小时的路程。我估计车速大约是每小时20公里，也就是每小时15英里。在这种路上我们根本快不起来。
Bump after bump after bump. And then finally, we got to the American base. And he's like, the Americans are over there. And we went further in to the main part of the city. It was like a little market in the middle of town. And I think everybody was looking at the car. Because everybody recognize white pickup trucks belong to my father, and they're like, ahh, governor's son's here. And as I entered I saw that there was a bunch of people in there waiting. And they were like, standing in a line. And so I was greeting everybody, and giving everyone a hug.
颠簸不断。最终，我们到达了美军基地。他指着说，美国人在那边。我们继续深入市区。那里是镇中心的一个小集市。我想每个人都在注视着这辆车。因为大家都认得那辆白色的皮卡属于我父亲，他们会说，啊，省长的儿子来了。当我走进大厅时，看到那里已经排着长队，许多人在等着。我便过去和每一个人打招呼，给每个人拥抱。
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
[讲外语]
Then my father came. And my mom was like, you better kiss your father's hand, don't forget to kiss it. Don't just go up there and hug him. You know people are going to be watching you, his son. And he's like the governor's there, so don't go and give him a hug and just like lift him up or anything. Just give him a kiss on the hand as a sign of respect. And then when you go inside you guys can talk and stuff. And so I remembered that.
然后我父亲来了。我母亲叮嘱我，一定要亲吻父亲的手，别忘了。不要只是走过去拥抱他。你知道大家都看着你，你是他的儿子。省长在那里，所以不要过去就给他一个拥抱或把他举起来之类的。亲吻他的手是一种尊重的表现。等进屋之后你们再谈。我记住了这些。
And I was like, I kissed his hand. And it was weird to finally see him in Kunar, sort of where he's grown up and everybody knows him. And it was weird to be in that kind of place where he belonged so much.
我吻了他的手。能在库纳尔见到他感觉很奇妙，毕竟那是他成长的地方，每个人都认识他。身处这样一个他如此归属的地方，感觉很奇怪。
Hello, hello. It's about 10:30 at night. I'm actually using a special flashlight that Americans gave to Sartore. He really likes it. It's a really cool-looking flashlight. It's a long tube thing. It's like those kinds you see and use them in the movies. Like The Fugitive , or stuff like that, where they look around in rooms.
喂，喂。现在是晚上10点半左右。我正在用美国人给萨托雷的一支特制手电筒。他非常喜欢它。那是一支看起来很酷的手电筒，是一个长管状的东西。就像你在电影里看到的那种，比如《亡命天涯》之类的，人们在房间里搜寻时用的那种。
So we're outside. It's pretty dark, because Kunar doesn't have electricity. The landscape's incredible. Mountains after mountains, and then rivers flowing underneath, and trees. It's a beautiful place. [SIGHS] There's still a lot of problems. It just seems like such a daunting task. These border areas, these tribal areas, all the history. I talked to my dad today about it. It seems like it's never been tamed. From the British, to the Russians, to everybody. To Alexander the Great. They've all struggled. And now my dad is trying.
我们现在在外面。外面很黑，因为库纳尔没有电。这里的风景美得令人难以置信。连绵不断的山脉，山下流淌着河流，还有树木。这是一个美丽的地方。[叹气] 但这里的问题仍然很多。这似乎是一项艰巨的任务。这些边境地区、部落区域以及所有的历史问题。我今天和我父亲谈过。这里似乎从来没有被征服过。从英国人、俄国人，到每一个人，甚至是亚历山大大帝。他们都挣扎过。而现在，我父亲正在尝试。
Like any of the people in the government right now, I read somewhere in an article, they joked. They said they wouldn't be good life insurance policy candidates. And it's true. [SIGHS] It's really weird to take walks with my dad and have armed guards walking around with me.
就像现在政府里的任何人一样，我在某篇文章里看到，他们开玩笑说自己不是人寿保险单的好人选。这是真的。[叹气] 和父亲一起散步，身边跟着武装警卫，这种感觉真的很奇怪。
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[嘈杂的对话声]
I'm just talking to my dad right now. We're walking by the river. This is usually where we take our walks. There's a little stairway down to the riverside from the house. We're walking alongside there with my dad.
我刚才正在和我父亲交谈。我们正走在河边。这是我们通常散步的地方。从房子到河边有一条小台阶。我们正沿着河边走。
It's been interesting to talk to my dad about some of the problems he's facing in Kunar. There's the obvious ones, like interference from Taliban, or Al-Qaida. There's the opium.
和我父亲聊聊他在库纳尔面临的一些问题很有意思。有显而易见的，比如塔利班或基地组织的干扰。还有鸦片问题。
But one of the problems that's not being reported much about, but is becoming somewhat of a serious problem, is the re-emergence of the Afghan communists. They are not ideologically communists. They were just people that fought on the Soviet side during the resistance. These people have become police chiefs, have gotten high positions in the interior ministry, the defense ministry, and this has brought back former tormentors over the people that they tormented. And this is creating problems. Especially in Kunar.
但有一个问题很少被报道，却正在成为一个严重的问题，那就是阿富汗共产主义者的死灰复燃。他们并非在意识形态上是共产主义者，他们只是曾在抵抗运动期间站在苏联那一边的人。这些人现在成了警察局长，在内政部、国防部获得了高位，这导致昔日的施暴者又回到了那些被他们迫害的人面前。这引发了很多问题。特别是在库纳尔。
My dad has told me about this mass grave right next to us here. This was actually done, I think, during let's say around 1978. What they did, the communists, what they did was they called all the tribal elders in this area. So about 1,200 men were called up. And once the 1,200 people came, the communists they started gunning down basically everybody.
我父亲向我讲述了我们身边那个乱葬岗的事。我想那是1978年左右发生的事情。那些共产主义者把这个地区所有的部落长老都叫了过来。大约有1200名男人被召集到这里。当这1200人到齐后，他们基本上就把所有人枪杀了。
And so it's a really huge blow to these people, to see these people back in the government after the massacres like that. And so anyway, I'll probably discuss it more when I'm there with the people that were there. There's some people that survived it.
所以，在这样的屠杀之后，看到这些人又回到了政府里，这对当地人来说是一个巨大的打击。总之，我可能会在我见到那些亲历者的时候再深入讨论。有些人幸存了下来。
OK, I'm walking to it now. The person that was here actually survived. So he's going to come and tell us exactly what happened. It's usually locked, so he has to open it. Turning the door. OK, I'm inside the place. You can hear me walking over the leaves.
好的，我现在正走过去。这里确实有一位幸存者。他会过来告诉我们到底发生了什么。门通常是锁着的，所以他得去开门。转动门锁。好了，我进来了。你能听到我走在落叶上的声音。
I didn't want to get too close with the mic. As soon as he walked in he burst into tears. You see huge bumps in the middle, rising up. I'd say four feet high. That's where the people were piled up on, buried. I see a really old hat. It's probably one of the people's hats that were killed here. Because they left the place just like it was.
我不想把麦克风靠得太近。他一进来就泪流满面。你能看到中间隆起巨大的土堆，大约有四英尺高。那里就是人们被堆在一起掩埋的地方。我看到一顶很旧的帽子。那可能是被杀的人戴的帽子，因为他们就让这个地方保持着原样。
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
[讲外语]
So he's basically telling me what happened. He came by this bridge that's about 30 yards away from here. And he said, I saw like a fire in here. And I saw this cloud of smoke, and a lot of red. I saw a lot of red, so I knew there was something going on, people being shot. He said when he got closer, he saw bulldozers. Right in this place where we're standing right now, he saw bulldozers climbing on top of the people.
他基本上是在告诉我当时发生的事情。他来到这里大约30码远的一座桥边。他说，我看到这里有火光。我看到了烟雾缭绕，还有一片血红。我看到很多红色，所以我知道出事了，有人在被枪杀。他说当他靠近时，他看到了推土机。就在我们现在站的地方，他看到推土机爬到了人们身上。
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
[讲外语]
He says he saw some of the people, they were pretending like they were killed. And they were just lying still because they thought that maybe, if we lie still here and pretend we're dead, they're just going to walk away. But then they started pulling the bulldozers ahead. And then they realized what was going on. And before they could do anything, they were just-- piles of dirt was piled upon them with the bulldozers. And they were buried in there alive.
他说他看到有些人假装被杀。他们只是静静地躺着，以为如果躺着装死，对方就会走开。但随后他们开始开动推土机。那时他们才意识到发生了什么。还没等他们采取任何行动，就被推土机推来的土堆掩埋了。他们被活活埋在那里。
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
[讲外语]
Another man's saying, to the right of me, he remembers it too. Because his grandmother had died and there was a funeral. So most people from his family were here. They grabbed his father, and they took him. And he said, I was only in fifth grade at that time, so I say, why are they grabbing my father?
另一个人也在说，在我右边的人，他也记得这件事。因为他的祖母去世了，当时有葬礼。所以他家里的大多数人都聚集在这里。他们抓住了他的父亲，把他带走了。他说，当时我才五年级，所以我问，为什么要抓我父亲？
He said, I ran after my father and I grabbed him by the hand to try to bring him back. And he said, the soldier just grabbed me by the shoulder, and threw me out in front of the house. And people, they just started gunning all of them down. And 63 other people were killed in this house in front of him. He says he remembers it like it was just a couple moments ago, because it was just done in front of his eyes.
他说，我追着父亲跑，抓住他的手想把他拉回来。他说，士兵一把抓住我的肩膀，把我扔到了房前。然后人们就开始对他们进行扫射。房前另有63人被杀。他说他记忆犹新，就像刚才发生的一样，因为这一切就发生在他的眼前。
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
[讲外语]
And he says, there's no elders in his family left. No fathers, no uncles, none of the fathers of his cousins, none of them are alive. So he says, I'm the oldest person left in the family. And that was his hat.
他说，他家里的长辈一个都不剩了。没有父亲，没有叔叔，没有表兄弟的父亲，全都没了。所以他说，我是家里剩下的最年长的人。那顶帽子就是他的。
It's amazing. At first, they were all tentative to talk. But when the elder came to me and told me about his story of surviving, all these young, not young guys, but like guys in their 30s, are coming up to me now. And everybody has a story. Everybody wants to pour their heart out. And if I could, I'd dedicate the whole hour to them on the radio. So they could just get their story out.
太不可思议了。起初他们都有些犹豫不决。但当那位长者过来告诉我他幸存的故事后，所有年轻——也不是年轻人，大概30多岁的人——都向我涌来。每个人都有一个故事。每个人都想倾诉心声。如果可以的话，我愿意把电台节目整整一个小时的时间都献给他们，让他们讲出自己的故事。
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
[讲外语]
It's so tragic that like, nobody even knows their story. I mean, there's lines dedicated to the massacre here and there in certain books. Like, on April 20, 1979, in a village outside of Islamabad called Kerala, 1,147 people were killed. Have you ever read the Revelations in the Holy Bible? It's like judgment day, or the day the world ends. It must have been like that for them. The sky becoming red, and the ground shaking, because there's people trapped alive that want to get out. I mean, imagine going through that. Being a little boy or a little girl watching all of that happen. Or a woman watching her husband and all her sons die like that.
真可悲，竟然没几个人知道他们的故事。我的意思是，在某些书里只有寥寥几行提到过这场屠杀。比如，1979年4月20日，在伊斯兰堡外一个叫克拉拉的村庄，有1147人被杀。你读过《圣经》里的《启示录》吗？那就像是审判日，或者是世界末日。对他们来说一定也是那样。天空变红，大地颤抖，因为还有人活着被困在下面想逃出来。我的意思是，想象一下经历那种场面。作为一个小男孩或小女孩，看着这一切发生。或者一个女人看着她的丈夫和所有的儿子就这样死去。
And like how can you even expect this person to want to go on, and want to rebuild and reconstruct. You just wish you had a trillion dollars and you could just build everything for them. And just tell them to sit home and just relax.
你怎么能指望这样的人想要继续生活，想要重建呢？你真希望自己有一万亿美元，能为他们建造一切。然后告诉他们回家好好休息就行了。
Tomorrow should be interesting. I am going with the Americans to an area called Korengal. There's a problem. One of the communists have gone to Korengal, and he's done a lot of bad things there. There's been a lot of complaints from there. So the Americans want to take that guy. His name is Shah Wali. They want to take Shah Wali to Korengal in Kunar and face his accusers. And it's going to be pretty exciting to see how the Americans work and how they talk with people.
明天应该会很有趣。我将和美国人一起去一个叫科伦加尔的地方。那里有个问题。有一个共产主义者去了科伦加尔，在那做了很多坏事。那里有很多投诉。所以美国人想带那个人去。他的名字叫沙·瓦利。他们想把沙·瓦利带到库纳尔的科伦加尔与他的指控者对质。看看美国人如何工作以及如何与人交谈，会很令人兴奋。
One of the problems is, the Americans like professional people. Professional people here are the communists. Those are the only professional people left here that were trained by the Russians in military or police work. And the Americans like working with them, because they're organized. It's been really interesting with the Americans. I've met the Americans now. They know I'm here. And when I talk to Americans it feels like, oh, there's my countrymen. The other people tease me like that too, the people around here. Like the security guards, and like Sartore and them tease me about it. You know, like, your tribe, there's your tribe, when they see the Americans.
其中一个问题是，美国人喜欢专业人士。这里的专业人士就是那些共产主义者。那是剩下的唯一受过俄国人训练的军事或警察工作的专业人员。美国人喜欢和他们共事，因为他们很有组织性。和美国人接触真的很有趣。我现在认识了这些美国人。他们知道我在这里。当我与美国人交谈时，感觉就像，哦，这是我的同胞。周围的人也这样取笑我，那些保安、萨托雷他们，当看到美国人时会拿我开玩笑，说，你的部落，你的部落在那边。
Good, how are you? You know how long it's going to take to Korengal?
你好，你好吗？你知道去科伦加尔要多长时间吗？
About two and a half hours.
大概两个半小时。
Two and a half hours?
两个半小时？
So around 5:30 in the morning I went over to the American base with my uncle. We're on our way. My uncle's name is Abdul Rauf but people usually refer to him as either Mullah Rauf or Commander Rauf. I usually just refer to him as mama, which means uncle.
所以凌晨5点半左右，我带着叔叔去了美军基地。我们在路上了。我叔叔的名字叫阿卜杜勒·劳夫，但人们通常叫他劳夫毛拉或劳夫指挥官。我通常只叫他“妈妈”（mama），也就是叔叔的意思。
Mullah Rauf is really respected. He was probably one of the biggest commanders fighting against the Soviets. He's lost an eye. He's been injured severely two, three times. He doesn't really have any formal relationship with the Americans. He's basically there helping out my dad, almost as his unofficial deputy. I'm traveling now with the Americans. I'm in a car with Dave from Indiana, Keith, and John, and Rauf mama.
劳夫毛拉非常受人尊敬。他可能是抵抗苏联斗争中最大的指挥官之一。他失去了一只眼睛。他受过两三次重伤。他和美国人之间其实没有什么正式的关系。他基本上是在那里帮我父亲，几乎就是他不公开的副手。我现在和美国人一起旅行。我和来自印第安纳州的戴夫、基思、约翰以及劳夫叔叔坐在一辆车里。
And then we finally got there. I guess that you could call it the equivalent of a town hall. It was just like a really small room. Mattresses on the floor, a couple of chairs inside.
最后我们到了那里。我想你可以称之为市政厅的翻版。那只是一个很小的房间。地板上有床垫，里面有几把椅子。
The reason we came up here was two-fold. His father represents President Karzai. President Karzai has imposed a-- what you call it, it's a moratorium. Anyway, he's preventing people from cutting down all the trees.
我们来这里有两个目的。他父亲代表卡尔扎伊总统。卡尔扎伊总统下达了一个——怎么说呢，是一个暂停令。总之，他禁止人们砍伐树木。
Kunar obviously doesn't have much of an economy. But one of the few things that Kunar has is really rare in Afghanistan, and that's timber.
库纳尔显然没有多少经济来源。但库纳尔拥有的为数不多的东西之一，在阿富汗非常稀有，那就是木材。
His reason is, unless you have a program to regrow the trees, it's going to have a bad effect.
他的理由是，除非你有重新植树的项目，否则这会产生负面影响。
And so many people going into the mountains, cutting down wood, and there's a lot of money involved. And it's supporting Al-Qaida, or Taliban, or people that are against the government. My uncle had never heard of it. But he said there's this weird thing, it's called [? a chinsa ?] And I was like, [? a chinsa ?]. What is a [? chinsa? ?] And he was like, it's a really weird equipment that can cut down trees really fast. And he's like, it's called a [? chinsa. ?]
所以很多人走进山里，砍伐树木，这背后涉及大量资金。它在支持基地组织、塔利班或那些反对政府的人。我叔叔以前从没听说过这个。但他提到有个奇怪的东西，叫“chinsa”。我问，chinsa？什么是chinsa？他说，那是一种非常奇怪的工具，砍树非常快。他说，这叫“chinsa”。
He's like, we went into the mountains one time to look for these people, to see if they really were cutting down trees. And he's like, I heard a motor in the background. I thought somebody was on a motorcycle somewhere off in the distance. And one of the soldiers told me, oh no, that's a [? chinsa. ?] And I obviously realized, it's a chainsaw. And maybe somebody brought it over from China to Pakistan, and then they sold it to people there. And by the time it goes into Afghanistan, it turns into a [? chinsa. ?]
他说，有一次我们走进山里去搜寻这些人，看看他们是否真的在砍树。他说，我听到背景里有发动机声。我以为是远处有人骑摩托车。结果其中一个士兵告诉我，哦不，那是“chinsa”。我显然意识到，那是电锯（chainsaw）。也许有人把它从中国带到巴基斯坦，然后卖给那里的人。当它进入阿富汗时，就变成了“chinsa”。
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE] What was the third one?
[讲外语] 第三个是什么？
At first, the translator was doing an all right job. But then I had to interrupt him several times. So around this time, I took over the translation.
起初，翻译做得还可以。但后来我不得不几次打断他。所以在那之后，我接过了翻译的工作。
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
[讲外语]
The second reason is that there was a problem that was up here a few months ago.
第二个原因是，几个月前这里出了点问题。
So then he started talking about the second reason why they were there, and that was because of the ex-communist, Shah Wali.
于是他开始谈论他们在那里的第二个原因，那是因为那个前共产主义者沙·瓦利。
We brought Shah Wali up here, we have the elders here, so that we don't have a repeat of this problem in the future. Just because people don't like other people, there's a personality conflict, OK? It doesn't mean that you can't follow the duly appointed people in those positions.
我们把沙·瓦利带到这里，长老们也都在，这样我们就不会在未来再遇到这种问题。只是因为人们不喜欢其他人，存在人格冲突，对吧？这并不意味着你不能服从在这些职位上的人。
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
[讲外语]
They're really trying to establish authority there, the Americans are. And Shah Wali was a person of authority. But, this is just a corrupt official that takes bribes, steals money. And that's what the problem came down to. They refused to make the payments of him asking for bribes. And the Americans saw it as a refusal to pay tax. And not accepting authority, or not obeying authority.
美国人真的在努力在那里建立权威。沙·瓦利曾经是个有权威的人。但这就是个收受贿赂、偷盗公款的腐败官员。而问题就在于此。他们拒绝支付他索要的贿赂。而美国人将其视为拒绝纳税。以及不接受权威或不服从权威。
What I was going to say, for instance, in the United States, if I get fined from a policeman for driving too fast. But I think I was driving the speed limit, OK. I don't shoot the policeman, OK.
我想说的是，比如在美国，如果警察因为我开车超速给我开罚单。但我认为我是在限速内行驶的，好的。我不会射杀警察，对吧？
Yeah, OK.
对，没问题。
I don't run him over and say, I'm not going to listen to you, because I was right and you were wrong. I go through the official system.
我不会撞倒他说，我不听你的，因为我是对的而你是错的。我会走官方程序。
OK. [SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
好的。[讲外语]
This policeman analogy, if you really want to use it. Now imagine that this policeman had come into your house, and had robbed you like a year ago, and maybe killed a couple kids or two for you. And just walked out of your house, and then you started fighting him for like six months. And then, like the ninth one he comes and gives you a speeding ticket for going 55 in a 60 mile an hour. That would be more an accurate analogy about what happened.
这个警察的比喻，如果你非要用的话。现在想象一下，这个警察一年前闯进了你的家，抢劫了你，可能还杀了你的两个孩子。然后走出你的家，接着你和他打了半年仗。然后，第九个月，他过来给你开了一张在限速60英里的路上开55英里的超速罚单。这才是关于发生了什么的更准确的类比。
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
[讲外语]
He says, we understand that we have to obey the central government, the provincial government. And we do obey them. But he said, if there's some guys coming here, like thuggery, or you know sort of running it like a mafia, then that you know, I can't be responsible for that. Let's bring out the people.
他说，我们明白必须服从中央政府、省级政府。我们也服从他们。但他表示，如果有一些人在这里搞暴行，像黑手党一样经营，那我对此不能负责。我们把人带出来吧。
So Shah Wali comes in and starts talking also. And when he starts talking, it's really super fast. So you can tell, he's a little worried.
沙·瓦利进来也开始说话。当他说话时，语速极快。你可以看出，他有点担心。
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
[讲外语]
It's not really resolved at all. When he got there, he was with the Americans. And so most of the people that had been robbed by him, or that had been beaten by him, or that had their money stolen, or whatever, were too afraid to say anything. And Americans thought everything was OK. And OK, let's take a picture now. So we decided to take a picture.
根本没解决任何问题。当他到那里时，他是和美国人在一起的。所以大多数被他抢劫过、被他打过、被偷过钱的人，都太害怕了，不敢说话。美国人以为一切都很好。好吧，现在拍照吧。所以我们决定拍照。
I want to get a picture of him shaking Shah Wali's hand. [LAUGHTER]
我想拍一张他和沙·瓦利握手的照片。[笑声]
There you go, they hugged right there.
就是这样，他们在那握了手。
Most of the mujahideen are like the Mullah Rauf. They're proud people. Not the kind of people that will go right away and kiss somebody's ass for a job. But the communists are willing to do that. They've worked for foreigners before, they'll do it again. And that really, in Kunar, it's gotten to a serious point. Where it's the same communist people now, it's just a different group of white people with them. It was just exactly what they would say, you know.
大多数圣战者都像劳夫毛拉那样。他们是自豪的人。不是那种为了工作立刻就去拍马屁的人。但共产主义者愿意那样做。他们以前为外国人工作过，还会再做一次。在库纳尔，这已经到了严重的地步。现在还是那些共产主义者，只是和他们在一起的白人换了一拨。这正是他们会说的那样。
And so it's important for the Americans to see who they befriend. It's causing serious damage to them.
所以美国人看清他们结交的对象很重要。这正在给他们造成严重损害。
Everybody's calm downed, you see. Let's talk now about some of the problems, and I'm going to let some of the other people speak in the room now. Major Doug will talk about the projects we can do to bring peace and stability.
大家都冷静下来了，你看到了。现在让我们谈谈一些问题，我要让房间里的其他人发言了。道格少校将谈谈我们可以做些什么项目来带来和平与稳定。
Next we started talking about school projects, or clinics, maybe a bridge. And I think Shah Wali was just like, one incident, where this could mean a lot of permanent changes for them. So I think the school and bridges were more important for them.
接下来我们开始谈论学校项目、诊所，或者一座桥。我想沙·瓦利只是一个插曲，而这些可能对他们意味着巨大的持久改变。所以我认为学校和桥梁对他们来说更重要。
I'm going to tell you that I cannot promise you we're going to build you a clinic, a school, a road or a bridge. I will not promise you that. And if another soldier promised you that, I can't guarantee that those things are going to happen. I can tell you that we have submitted the paperwork to try and build a school here. But I am waiting on approval from my generals to see if we can do that.
我要告诉你，我不能向你们保证我们会为你们建诊所、学校、道路或桥梁。我不会做这样的承诺。如果其他的士兵向你承诺过，我不能保证这些事情一定会发生。我只能告诉你，我们已经提交了在这里建学校的申请文件。但我正在等待将军们的批准，看看我们是否能这样做。
Seems like nobody could make a decision. Or nobody can make a promise, except for Bush or somebody. Because everybody else has somebody higher up above them who has the real authority, who they're going to have to wait for what they decide. So it does kind of disappoint people at times. And they do not seem like the strongest of allies when they can't even promise a bridge to them.
似乎没人能做决定。或者没人能做出承诺，除了布什或谁。因为其他人上面都有更高级别的人，握有真正的权力，他们必须等待上级的决定。所以有时这确实会让人们感到失望。当他们连一座桥都承诺不了的时候，看起来并不像是最强大的盟友。
Coming up, things get more dangerous. A lot more dangerous. Plus, a kitten. When Hyder Akbar's story continues in the second half of our program. From Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
接下来，情况会变得更危险。危险得多。还有，一只小猫。当海德尔·阿克巴尔的故事在我们节目的后半部分继续时。来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台，在我们的节目继续时。
This is This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. If you're just tuning in, we're devoting our entire program today to Hyder Akbar's audio diaries from Afghanistan. Hyder was 18 years old when he recorded these, in the summer of 2003, in Kunar Province, where his dad was governor. And we pick up where we left off. Hyder is out with US forces.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。如果你刚调过来，我们今天整期节目都在播放海德尔·阿克巴尔从阿富汗发回的音频日记。2003年夏天，海德尔在库纳尔省记录下这些时年仅18岁，当时他父亲是省长。我们接着刚才的话题继续。海德尔正在与美军在一起。
We're on our way back, and I guess they've seen like a wire on the road. And they think it's a mine, so we've stopped. They're all getting out of the car, to make sure everything's OK. They've seen a wire, so they want to make sure they're not going to get ambushed or anything.
我们在回来的路上，我想他们看到路上一根电线。他们认为那是地雷，所以我们停下了。他们都下了车，确保一切正常。他们看到了一根电线，所以想确保不会遭到伏击。
Is there something going on?
发生了什么事吗？
Yeah, there's a wire across the road down there.
是的，路上有一根电线。
Sure.
当然。
An old man and old woman, they were walking together. We passed them coming down. We can hike up to them, but--
一对老夫妇，他们一起走着。我们经过他们时他们正走下来。我们可以徒步走到他们那里，但是——
They saw a man up above us, higher on the road. And he was just sitting there with his wife.
他们看到我们上方路边有一个人。他正和妻子坐在那里。
Anyone want to ask that [BEEP]-er if he's got a phone on him, or a radio?
有人想问问那个混蛋身上有没有手机或对讲机吗？
Does he have a radio, because they thought maybe, he might have something with him. Or maybe he's the signal guy. And they were just being extra careful to make sure there's not two men sitting there with just another man in the burka, or something like that.
他有对讲机吗？因为他们以为可能他身上有什么东西。或者他是个信号兵。他们只是格外小心，确保那里没有两个男人，或者穿着布卡的人假扮的，类似那样。
Yeah, he's got his wife with him. I don't think-- Can we call them over here?
是的，他和他妻子在一起。我觉得不应该——我们可以把他们叫过来吗？
It's his wife. You're not going to disturb his wife, right?
那是他的妻子。你不去打扰他的妻子，对吧？
Yeah.
是的。
You could tell he was a poor guy, just, you know, had like a shawl around him, but a really beat up shawl. And he was absolutely terrified. He was like, who are these people walking up towards me? You know he's just a man on the side of the road sitting down.
你可以看出他是个穷人，你知道，身上披着条披肩，但那是条很破旧的披肩。他完全被吓坏了。他在想，这些人走向我是要干什么？你知道，他只是个坐在路边的男人。
They asked him, what are you doing here? He said we're taking a break, we got tired, we're sitting down here. Maybe if a car comes down, we'll hitch a ride. His wife is just sitting in the corner like a ghost.
他们问他，你在这里干什么？他说我们在休息，走累了，就坐在这里。如果有车经过，我们打算搭个便车。他的妻子像个鬼魂一样坐在角落里。
Please forgive us, as we've disturbed your rest.
请原谅我们，打扰了你们的休息。
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
[讲外语]
No, we don't have a problem. This is our country. We want peace and security, so we don't mind you guys taking measures.
不，我们没问题。这是我们的国家。我们想要和平与安全，所以我们不介意你们采取措施。
I'm always glad when I hear a humble man express that.
听到一个卑微的人表达这种意思，我总是很高兴。
?] [SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
？[讲外语]
If you see something in the road that looks like an explosive, or a wire, don't do anything about it yourself. Contact an official.
如果你在路上看到看起来像爆炸物或电线的东西，不要自己处理。联系官员。
After they're done, it almost sounds like the forest ranger at your local national park after he stops you when he thinks you have like a lighter in your hand. And you don't have a lighter in your hand. And then he gives you the little speech about, yeah, just in case, remember never to smoke.
事情结束后，这听起来简直就像是当地国家公园的护林员在你被拦截后，因为他觉得你手里有打火机而对你进行训话。实际上你手里并没有打火机。然后他给了你一番演讲，关于“是的，以防万一，记住永远不要吸烟”。
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE] [LAUGHTER]
[讲外语] [笑声]
We're heading back. They either got it cleared or realized it wasn't a danger. Have a good day, man.
我们要回去了。他们要么清除了威胁，要么意识到那根本没什么危险。祝你愉快，伙计。
So I guess they've either de-mined it, or it wasn't anything to begin with. So, you know. Every trip in Kunar is an adventure.
所以我猜他们要么是排除了地雷，要么本来就没东西。所以，你知道。库纳尔的每一趟旅程都是一次冒险。
Just got ambushed. We just got ambushed. You can hear the shots fired. You can hear the shots fired at us. We're being fired at. There was just a mine that blew up in front of us. I better get down. I better get down. We've been ambushed. I can't get down.
刚遭到伏击。我们刚刚遭到伏击。你能听到枪声。你能听到他们向我们开火。我们正受到攻击。刚才我们前面有一枚地雷爆炸了。我最好趴下。我最好趴下。我们遭到伏击了。我趴不下去。
Get down.
趴下。
I'm trying to get, how can I get down more than this? I can't duck down, I'm totally exposed. I'm totally exposed.
我正在试，我还能怎么趴得更低？我没法躲起来，我完全暴露了。我完全暴露了。
Reloading! Where they at? I can't see [BEEP].
换弹夹！他们在哪里？我什么都看不见，该死。
[SHOTS FIRING]
[枪声]
Wow.
哇。
Just stay down over there.
就趴在那里。
Yeah, yeah, I'm trying to stay down as much as I can.
好的，好的，我正尽量趴得低一点。
Just stay low.
保持低姿态。
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE] Mama is fine. [LAUGHTER]
[讲外语] 叔叔没事。[笑声]
Mama is joking, he's like, I'm fine. I've been through this a lot of times. But for me it's-- [GUNSHOTS] Welcome to Kunar. Phew. There's a rush of blood.
叔叔在开玩笑，他说，我没事。我经历过很多次这种情况了。但对我来说——[枪声] 欢迎来到库纳尔。呼。血流加速了。
OK, John, check our 3:00. Somebody's pointing to our 3.
好的，约翰，检查我们的3点钟方向。有人指着我们的3点钟方向。
No, no, I was pointing at him, telling him--
不，不，我是在指着他，告诉他——
Terry was pointing to our 3:00.
泰瑞指着我们的3点钟方向。
So let me explain what happened. A mine just blew up in front of us, so there was an ambush. They were trying to ambush us. There's a truck to the left of us. We're in the middle of a valley, mountains both side of us.
让我解释一下发生了什么。我们前面有一枚地雷爆炸了，所以发生了伏击。他们试图埋伏我们。我们左边有一辆卡车。我们在一个山谷中间，两边都是山。
We need to be moving, we need to be moving. Let's go! Get in! Get in!
我们需要行动，我们需要行动。走！进去！进去！
Getting in, we're leaving. You can see a pick-up from here. I guess they were killed. [GUNSHOTS] So we're moving pretty quickly, we're getting out of here.
进去了，我们要走了。你可以从这里看到一辆皮卡。我猜他们被杀了。[枪声] 我们动作很快，我们要撤了。
Stop, stop!
停下，停下！
We're stopping, we're stopping, they're coming out again. We're fighting again. There's more people, there's more people. Get down, get down.
我们要停下，我们停下了，他们又出来了。我们要再打。还有更多人，更多人。趴下，趴下。
9:00!
9点钟方向！
The general's running over here.
将军跑过来了。
You're going to have to relay commands from these guys, who are going to be on the radio. You're going to yell at me, I'm going to be on that hilltop with those AMF guys, OK?
你得负责传达这些在对讲机里指挥的人的命令。你要对着我喊，我会在那边那个小山头上和那些阿富汗民兵在一起，好吗？
All right, do you want me to get down?
好的，要我趴下吗？
No, you just, you stay in here, you stay safe. But if he has something that comes over the radio, you yell it to me, I'll hear you.
不，你就在这，保持安全。但如果他通过对讲机传达什么，你对我喊出来，我就能听见。
All right, all right, sure, I got it.
好的，好的，没问题。
Tell him to pull up his glass, so he doesn't get a bullet.
告诉他拉起玻璃，免得被流弹击中。
OK, OK. [SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
好的，好的。[讲外语]
Tell him he don't need to lose the other eye.
告诉他他不需要失去另一只眼睛。
[LAUGHTER] [SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
[笑声] [讲外语]
They joked with my uncle, they said tell him to put the window back up, we don't need him to lose the other eye. So they want me to-- he's going to run to that hill. He doesn't want me to get out of the car. I wouldn't mind getting out of the car. I kind of want to see what's going on. I'm surprisingly calm I guess you could say.
他们和叔叔开了个玩笑，说告诉他把窗户摇上去，我们不需要他失去另一只眼睛。所以他们想让我——他要跑到那个山丘上。他不希望我下车。我不介意下车。我其实想看看外面发生了什么。我出奇地冷静，或许可以说。
Hey, hey, yell to the chief, we're going to move. Get everybody back over here.
嘿，嘿，对着指挥官喊，我们要动了。让他们都回来。
Chief, we're going to move! Get everybody out of here! Back in the cars! I don't think he heard me. He was way down. Chief! All right, he's coming.
指挥官，我们要动了！让他们撤出来！回车里去！我觉得他没听见。他离得太远了。指挥官！好的，他过来了。
Load it up! Here's what's happening. We're going to bound through, our two vehicles. We'll take the lead, establish another support position. Then we're going to bound through and keep on going. You give me a [BEEPING]-ing thumbs up, let's go!
装上！事情是这样的。我们两辆车要冲过去。我们带头，建立另一个支援点。然后我们冲过去继续前进。给我一个大拇指，我们走！
Roger that!
收到！
Let's go! Get in the vehicle! Goddammit let's go!
走！上车！该死，快走！
Let's go!
走！
Wow. [GUNSHOTS] We're driving fast out of here. OK, we're out of here.
哇。[枪声] 我们飞快地驶离这里。好了，我们出来了。
Watch the civilians, guys!
注意平民，伙计们！
Once again, I really like mama's calmness. Real calm. He doesn't even have any-- He doesn't have a weapon. He doesn't have any, like armored vests or anything like the Americans. And I mean he's like the calmest out of all of them. It was a good experience, overall, a good experience. That might sound insane, but I'll explain later.
再一次，我真的很喜欢叔叔的镇定。真的很冷静。他甚至没有任何武器。他不像美国人那样有防弹衣之类的。我是说，他是所有人中最冷静的一个。总的来说这是一次很好的经历，一次很好的经历。这听起来可能很疯狂，但我稍后会解释。
OK, guys.
好的，伙计们。
We'll see you guys soon.
很快再见。
See you, soon. All right, buddy, we'll catch you later. Watch movies, do something.
再见。好的，伙计，回头见。看看电影，做点什么。
Yeah, watch movies. All right, man.
是的，看电影。好的，伙计。
OK, bye guys.
好的，再见。
All right, take care.
好的，保重。
I like [? how we went through ?] that baptism for Kunar. It almost helped me with a little bit of legitimacy now. All the security guards wanted to hear it. And they're like oh, he's not scared. So everybody was really happy.
我喜欢我们经历库纳尔洗礼的方式。这让我在某种程度上获得了一点合法性。所有的保安都想听这个。他们说哦，他一点也不怕。所以每个人都很高兴。
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
[讲外语]
And then my dad was sitting by the river, and he was sitting there with the people talking. I was like, I have to tell you something. He's like, all right, just wait until I'm done. I was like, no, no you have to get up for just a minute and talk. And he got up for a minute, and I told him what happened. I said, we got ambushed. He's like, did anybody get killed? I was like, no. Did anybody get injured? I said, no. And he's like, you really interrupted my meeting for that, Hyder? I was like, I got ambushed. And it was really funny to see that nobody else thought it was that exciting or it was that incredible. Compared to what they had been through, it's relatively exciting but not as serious as, you know, interrupting a meeting.
然后我父亲坐在河边，和人们坐在一起聊天。我说，我有事必须告诉你。他说，好的，等我忙完。我说，不，不，你得起来谈谈。他起来了一分钟，我告诉了他刚才发生的事。我说，我们被埋伏了。他说，有人被杀吗？我说，没。有人受伤吗？我说，没。他说，你就为了这个打断我的会议吗，海德尔？我说，我们被埋伏了。看到没有其他人觉得这件事有多激动或不可思议，这真有意思。相比他们所经历的一切，这相对令人激动，但还没严重到要打断会议的地步。
So that was really weird. And then it all of a sudden hit me, I was like whoa yeah, that's true. Maybe it isn't such a big deal for my dad, or maybe for my uncle, who's seen a lot of that.
这真的很奇怪。突然间我意识到，哇，确实如此。也许对我父亲，或者对我叔叔这样经历过很多此类事件的人来说，这没什么大不了的。
There's a helicopter above us who's patrolling because [INAUDIBLE] have been hit. I guess they're trying to deter the missile attacks that have been happening lately. There are missile attacks, that's been happening. It's about every night I've been here. It's not the most helpful thing when you're trying to go to sleep. It's really rude of Al-Qaida. It'd be much more convenient if they would launch them at like 12:00 or 11:00 in the afternoon. Like 12:00 noon.
头顶上有一架直升机在巡逻，因为[无法辨音]遭到了袭击。我猜他们想阻止最近发生的导弹袭击。有导弹袭击，这是真的。我待在这里的每一晚都有。当你试图入睡时，这可不是什么好事。基地组织的行为真的很粗鲁。如果他们能在中午12点发射，那就方便多了。
Because it doesn't last, it's not dangerous. It's basically used to scare donors from coming in. To scare NGOs from coming in. And to scare foreign aid money from coming in. And then that, it works, because they launch totally randomly, and it lands in some random ass field. But you know, reports go back to Kabul, border trouble area of Kunar got three rockets launched at it last night. And no overnight stay in Kunar for UN, and blah, blah, blah.
因为它持续时间不长，而且没什么危险。基本上就是为了吓跑捐赠者。吓跑非政府组织。吓跑外援资金。这奏效了，因为他们完全是随机发射的，落在一块随机的田里。但是你知道，报告会回到喀布尔，库纳尔边境麻烦区昨晚遭到三枚火箭弹袭击。于是联合国就不在库纳尔留宿了，等等之类的。
I've been talking about the missile attacks that have been happening a lot lately. And then there was one night where three rockets were launched within about a minute of each other, all towards the American base. And names started coming up. And one of the names was Abdul Wali, who is from our valley here. And Abdul Wali's brother got in contact with my dad. And we were really worried. They've heard all kinds of horror stories about what the Americans do.
我一直在谈论最近频繁发生的导弹袭击。有一个晚上，三枚火箭弹在不到一分钟内先后发射，全部瞄准美军基地。随后名字开始传出来。其中一个名字是阿卜杜勒·瓦利，他来自我们这个山谷。阿卜杜勒·瓦利的兄弟联系了我父亲。我们非常担心。他们听过各种关于美国人做法的恐怖故事。
And my dad talked to them and said, don't worry. I'll send my son personally with you to the American [UNINTELLIGIBLE] who will be there with you to translate, and talk to them. So I took him to the Americans. And like, they're asking him where he was 14 days ago, on the night of the three rockets. And this guy like, they don't have calendars, you know. Somebody asks you where you were 14 days ago, you're not going to, especially if you didn't do anything, you're not going to be able to tell.
父亲和他们谈了，说别担心。我亲自派我儿子陪你们去美国人的地方，他会和你们一起翻译，和他们交谈。于是我带他去了美国人那边。他们问他14天前，也就是三枚火箭弹发射的那个晚上他在哪里。这些人没有日历，你懂的。如果有人问你14天前你在哪里，你没做过什么事的话，你是不可能说出来的。
And they're like, oh no, you fired three rockets, how can you not know the night? Three rockets fired where you were. And like, we already think you're lying. And your situation is getting worse by the minute. It was hard to watch. I just put my hand on his shoulder, and I let him know. Just say the truth. Nothing is going to happen if you just say the truth. And he was absolutely petrified, and he could barely whisper the OK. And that was like my last words to him, and then I walked out.
他们说，哦不，你发射了三枚火箭弹，你怎么可能不知道那天晚上？三枚火箭弹在你所在的位置发射。我们已经认为你在撒谎了。你的处境正变得越来越糟。看着这一幕很难受。我只是把手放在他肩上，让他知道。说真话就行。如果你只说真话，什么事也不会发生。他完全被吓坏了，几乎只能低声说出“好吧”。那是对他说的最后一句话，然后我走出了门。
And maybe, maybe I am wrong. Maybe they do have very concrete evidence. Or maybe, like last time, let me tell you about the last time, what happened. There's a guy named Saleh Mohammed, OK. This guy's house had been attacked a couple times by the Americans. Weapons, caches, everything looked for a couple times. His women searched, his kids harassed. This guy was absolutely ashamed. He was ready to flee to Pakistan, just because the kind of shame that had been brought upon his family.
也许，也许我错了。也许他们确实有非常具体的证据。或者也许，就像上次一样。让我告诉你上次发生了什么。有一个人叫萨利赫·穆罕默德。这家伙的房子被美国人搜查过几次。武器、缓存，搜了几次。他的女人被搜查，孩子被骚扰。这家伙感到无比羞耻。他准备逃往巴基斯坦，仅仅因为这种耻辱带给了他的家庭。
It's a big deal here, to have that happen to you. And my dad sent him a letter, saying, if you're innocent, prove your innocence and come down to the capitol. He was so grateful, and he came down to the capitol right away.
在这里，发生这种事影响很大。我父亲寄给他一封信，说如果你是无辜的，证明你的清白，到首府来。他非常感激，立刻就来了。
And surely enough, three days later, Americans handed him back to my dad and said, do whatever you want to do with him. He's not a threat to us. And so the Americans had completely put him to shame. Had him ready to flee into the Punjab, Pakistan, and become a later recruit for Al-Qaida. All because of some bad information.
结果果然，三天后，美国人把他交还给我父亲，说想对他做什么就做什么。他对我们不构成威胁。所以美国人让他蒙受了彻底的羞耻。让他准备逃往巴基斯坦的旁遮普省，成为基地组织的后备招募者。一切仅仅因为错误的情报。
So you'd think maybe after something like that happens, they might hold their horses a little bit. I just hope everything goes OK, but in due time, we'll find out. Probably in about three days. I'm going to go to the American base to check up on him.
所以你会想，发生这种事后，他们也许会收敛一点。我只是希望一切顺利，但在适当的时候，我们会知道真相。可能在三天后吧。我要去美军基地看看他。
Today, it's been a hectic day, to say the least. Around I'd say, 5:30 or 6:00, a translator from the Americans come over. And said that Steve wants to talk, and he wants to talk now. And he was wondering if you could come to the base. So we got kind of worried, like, what could it be. Because usually they come to the palace, and say that they're waiting outside and if they could talk for a couple minutes. So this was the first time they wanted my dad to actually come there.
今天可以说是非常忙碌的一天。大约在5点半或6点左右，一个美军翻译过来了。他说史蒂夫想谈谈，而且是现在谈。他问你能不能去基地。我们感到很担心，会是什么事？因为通常他们都是来官邸，说他们在外面等着，问能不能谈几分钟。所以这是他们第一次要求我父亲亲自去那里。
So we arrived there. And we're waiting in the chair, me and my dad. Steve and Dave arrive, they come in, exchange greetings, they sit down. And then they go, unfortunately, we have some bad news. So I'm thinking, oh man, what happened. You know, is Abdul Wali not cooperating? Or did he admit to having a part in the missile attacks? What happened?
我们到了那里。我和父亲坐在椅子上等。史蒂夫和戴夫到了，他们进来，打过招呼，坐下。然后他们说，不幸的是，我们有一些坏消息。我想，噢，天哪，发生了什么。阿卜杜勒·瓦利不配合吗？还是他承认参与了导弹袭击？发生了什么？
And they're like, unfortunately, Abdul Wali passed away. My jaw dropped. I said, oh my God. And my dad was like, what? They said that, 3:30, 4:00, he just collapsed. And they tried to make him stand again. He stood for second, but then he fell again. And then they did the whole routine, with the CPR, and they said no expenses were held. And just like they would have treated an American life.
他们说，不幸的是，阿卜杜勒·瓦利去世了。我目瞪口呆。我说，天哪。我父亲问，什么？他们说，3点半、4点左右，他倒下了。他们试图让他站起来，他站了一会儿，但又倒下了。然后他们做了整套心肺复苏程序，说没有吝惜费用，就像对待美国人的生命一样。
And then we went into like, the torture, and anything like that, and nothing like that was done. He was being treated right, and given like power bars, and stuff like that. He would put rocks in his mouth, but then they thought, maybe it's because he's used to chewing tobacco. He had tried to-- with the shackles that had binded his feet together-- try to break those. And he hit his head against the wall a couple times, trying to work with that. And just for our sake, they wanted us to see the body to make sure nothing had happened to it.
然后我们谈到了刑讯之类的，说没有发生那种事。他受到了很好的对待，给了他能量棒之类的东西。他会把石头放进嘴里，但他们以为他是因为习惯了咀嚼烟草。他曾试图用绑着双脚的镣铐——尝试打破它们。他曾几次用头撞墙，试图解决这个问题。为了我们着想，他们希望我们看看尸体，以确保没有发生什么事。
So we go see his body. His body was kept in his cell, or whatever it was. And the cell was pretty bad condition, I have to be honest. And inside, lay him with a sheet over his body. It was extremely hot and damp. And my dad took the towel off his face. One of his eyes was open, the other was closed. No marks on him. I touched his face. I touched his chest. And he was dead. And it's like, this is extremely good propaganda for Al-Qaida, Taliban. Hey, guys. Don't go to Americans. Don't listen to Said Fazel Akbar, or you'll end up like Abdul Wali. Remember Abdul Wali. You are going to die like him, if you go to him. So, so bad for us.
于是我们去看了他的尸体。他的尸体被放在牢房里，或者不管那是什么。说实话，牢房条件很差。里面，他的尸体上盖着一块布。那里极其闷热潮湿。父亲把盖在他脸上的毛巾拿开。他的一只眼睛睁着，另一只闭着。身上没有任何伤痕。我摸了他的脸。摸了他的胸部。他死了。这对基地组织、塔利班来说是极好的宣传材料。嘿，伙计们。不要去找美国人。不要听赛义德·法泽尔·阿克巴尔的话，否则你会像阿卜杜勒·瓦利那样。记住阿卜杜勒·瓦利。如果你去找他，你也会像他那样死去。这对我们太糟糕了。
But aside from politics, it just feels so personal for me. This guy was saying bye to me, like, make sure nothing happens to me. Like, the day before yesterday. And it's hard not to feel responsible. Poor guy was only 28. He was just so scared. How did he die? That was not how it's supposed to happen.
但抛开政治不谈，对我来说这感觉太私人了。这个人前天还对我告别，说请确保我没事。我很难不感到自责。可怜的家伙才28岁。他只是太害怕了。他怎么死的？事情本不该这样发展的。
After his death, they were ready to do an autopsy to investigate. The people there of course, they don't know what an autopsy is. It would probably be the worst thing you can do, if they brought him back and he had cuts opened up in him, then sewn back together. They're like, oh wow yeah, this is how he died, they just cut him up right through the middle. But there was even a lawyer from Washington there.
他死后，他们准备进行尸检调查。当地人当然不知道什么是尸检。如果他们把他送回来，发现身上有切开的口子，再缝起来，那可能是你能做的最糟糕的事。他们会说，哦，天哪，看，他是这样死的，他们就在中间把他切开了。但那里甚至有一个来自华盛顿的律师。
And that's when I realized that it was a much bigger deal than I had thought of before. And I'm probably one of very few civilians to have witnessed an interrogation of a suspected terrorist by US forces. His death has barely been reported in the Western press.
那时我才意识到，这比我之前想的要严重得多。而且我可能是极少数目睹美国军队审讯恐怖分子嫌疑人的平民之一。他的死亡在西方媒体上几乎没有报道。
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
[讲外语]
[TRANSLATING] What has been your most difficult day being the governor of Kunar so far?
[翻译] 迄今为止，作为库纳尔省长，你最困难的一天是什么？
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
[讲外语]
[TRANSLATING] If I had to choose one day as being my most difficult day, it would have to be the day that Abdul Wali died. American forces were ready to use military force to capture this person. And I told them to please hold on and let me try and get a hold of him myself. And since this man trusted me, and since they trusted our family name, the man did arrive to Kunar, and did turn himself into us. He claimed his innocence, but he was incredibly fearful of what the Americans might do to him.
[翻译] 如果非要选出最困难的一天，那一定是阿卜杜勒·瓦利死的那天。美军准备使用武力逮捕此人。我告诉他们请等一等，让我亲自尝试联系他。因为这个人信任我，也信任我们家族的名字，他确实来到了库纳尔，并自首了。他声称自己是无辜的，但他非常担心美国人可能会对他做什么。
And since he was so fearful, I sent you along to prove to him that there's no trouble. And that I'll send my own son with you as a sign of trust. And so, his family told us later on, and his brother told us, also, that he did have heart problems. But this was such a difficult day to me, because of all the backup I have received, of all of the support I have received from the people of Kunar, this did leave a dent in it. Because people were more hesitant now to come to me.
因为他太害怕了，我派你陪他去，向他证明不会有事。我派我自己的儿子陪你作为信任的标志。所以，他的家人后来告诉我们，他的兄弟也告诉我们，他确实有心脏问题。但这对我来说是如此艰难的一天，因为库纳尔人民给予我的所有支持，在这个时刻留下了裂痕。因为现在人们更犹豫着要不要来找我了。
What you hear in the background is actually a tap dancer. It's a tradition in Kunar. They tap dance. And you can hear it off in the distance, tap dancing in the cement outside. [LAUGHTER] I'm totally kidding. That's the fan rattling above me. It just sounds like somebody's tap dancing [UNINTELLIGIBLE] off in the distance. But it's actually the fan. There's no tap dancing experts in Kunar yet.
背景里听到的是踢踏舞者的声音。这是库纳尔的传统。他们跳踢踏舞。你可以听到远处水泥地上的踢踏舞声。[笑声] 我开玩笑的。那是上面的风扇在嘎嘎响。它听起来就像有人在远处跳踢踏舞[无法辨音]。但那其实是风扇。库纳尔还没有踢踏舞专家。
I'll be going to Bajaur tomorrow. Bajaur is on Pakistan's side of the border. I'm going there tomorrow because that's actually where my uncle lives. Like that's where his home is. He has a 35 room basically fort, along with his five brothers. I'll be going there tomorrow, probably spend a couple nights there.
明天我要去巴贾尔。巴贾尔在边境的巴基斯坦一侧。我明天要去那里，因为那就是我叔叔住的地方，那是他的家。他和他的五个兄弟拥有一座35个房间的堡垒。我明天要去那里，可能会待上两晚。
I'm at my uncle's guest house. And he's going to get out in about a minute, and we're going to have a quick tour of his house. OK, mama's out. We're about to leave the guest house, and enter like the main house.
我在叔叔的客房。他一分钟后就要出来了，我们要去参观一下他的房子。好的，叔叔出来了。我们准备离开客房，进入主屋。
It's a huge room. Tall ceilings, basically like the garage. This is where they store all the foods in like huge sacks. And they actually have our old bags here, too. When we went to America, in '87, we gave them some things to keep. And they still have them in here. And you come out here.
这是一个巨大的房间。天花板很高，基本上像个车库。这里存着所有装在大袋子里的粮食。他们甚至还留着我们的旧袋子。当我们在87年去美国时，我们留了一些东西给他们保管。他们现在还存放在这。从这里出来。
Let me just count how many kids are around me right now. 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12, 13, 14, 15, 16 walked out of that corner. 17. I just counted 17 of them. Like little, little kids. Basically this is where they get their water from, they store it in a tank, and then pour it into buckets and stuff and carry it around.
让我数数周围有多少个孩子。1，2，3，4，5，6，7，8，9，10，11，12，13，14，15，16，从那个角落走出来。17。我刚刚数了17个。都是很小很小的孩子。基本上他们从这里取水，储存在一个水箱里，然后倒进桶里到处拎着。
OK, we're going to enter another place now.
好的，我们要进另一个地方了。
This is the first time I met mama's wife, she's sitting here. This is mama's room. This is his personal room, this is where he sleeps.
这是我第一次见到叔叔的妻子，她坐在那。这是叔叔的房间。这是他的私人房间，他睡这里。
My uncle is just about the toughest person you'll ever meet. I mean, I don't want to speculate the number of people he's probably killed. Or the number of times he's almost been killed. Or the number of times he's been, you know, wounded during the war.
我叔叔简直是你见过最强悍的人。我的意思是，我不想推测他杀过多少人。或者他差点死掉的次数。或者他在战争中受伤的次数。
Like there's really small pieces of shrapnel like, they almost look like crumbs, that are just some places in his body. The other day, one of them was coming out of his forehead. He was like, hey Hyder, can you help me here. I'm like yeah, sure. There's like something coming out here. Check it out. I checked it out and pulled, it was like a little metal piece. He said, oh, I think it's shrapnel, can you help me pull it out? I've been working on it for three days, it's slowly coming out of my skin.
就像身体里有一些像碎屑一样的小弹片。前几天，其中一颗从他的前额钻了出来。他说，嘿，海德尔，你能帮我一下吗？我说好的。有一个东西钻出来了。我检查了一下，拔出来，那是一小块金属。他说，哦，我想那是弹片，你能帮我把它拔出来吗？我研究了三天，它正慢慢从我的皮肤里钻出来。
A funny story, the other day, there was a kitten. And my uncle saw it. And he's like, oh, look at that kitten. It's ran away from home or something. He's like, I think we should go get it some milk. And the soldiers are like looking around, like giggling with each other, like what the hell. Is this Mullah Rauf? And he told his soldiers, go get some milk, man! Hurry up! And so they ran to go get some milk. He brought the milk, and he brought this like little plate. And he poured it himself. And he was like, [KISSING NOISES] towards the kitten to have some of the milk.
一个有趣的故事，前几天有一只小猫。我叔叔看到了。他说，哦，看那只小猫。它大概离家出走了。他说，我想我们应该给它弄点牛奶。士兵们互相看了看，偷笑，说这到底是劳夫毛拉吗？他告诉士兵，去搞点牛奶，伙计！快点！于是他们跑去弄牛奶。他带回牛奶，还带了一个盘子。他亲自倒上。他对着小猫发出[亲吻声]的声音，让它喝奶。
And it was the absolutely funniest thing to watch this guy with this big ass beard, and one eye, and metal coming out of his forehead, like, asking this kitten to get some milk.
看着这个长着大胡子、只有一只眼、前额还冒着金属的家伙，那样哄着小猫喝奶，绝对是最逗的事情。
Now I'm going to go ahead and interview my uncle. Because he's really had a life that's pretty much unimaginable. And now-- whoop. You just heard the light go out. You didn't hear the lights go out, we heard the electricity break down. The fence turned off. It's going to be really hot now. So I just want to give a little history of why he came here, and why he became a refugee in Pakistan.
现在我要采访我的叔叔了。因为他的生活简直令人难以置信。现在——哎呀。你刚听到灯灭了。你没听到灯灭，我们听到了停电。电扇停了。现在会很热。所以我只想简单介绍一下他为什么来这里，以及为什么成为巴基斯坦的难民。
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
[讲外语]
[TRANSLATING] This is probably around 1980. These Russians came with these bulletproof vests on. And at that time, we didn't know what they were. I started shooting at them, emptied like all 30 of my bullets into him. And all they'd do is just make a scream, like odd noise, and push back a little.
[翻译] 这大概是1980年左右。那些俄国人穿着防弹衣来了。那时我们不知道那是什么。我开始向他们射击，把30发子弹全都打光了。他们只是发出尖叫，像奇怪的声音，后退了一点。
He says it wouldn't penetrate them at all. And he said, it totally spooked me out. And so he said we went home and we decided that these new kinds of Soviets, they are going to create problems for us. Not even bullets can penetrate them. So we decided to come to Pakistan, and become refugees in Pakistan. And at first, he said, we came here in tents. And we lived in tents for a while. Then slowly, slowly, we started building these houses.
他说子弹根本打不穿。他说，这彻底吓到了我。所以我们回家决定，这些苏联人会给我们带来大麻烦。连子弹都打不穿他们。所以我们决定来巴基斯坦，成为难民。起初，他说，我们住在帐篷里。我们住了很久的帐篷。然后慢慢地，我们开始建造这些房子。
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
[讲外语]
My uncle started writing with himself, I'm like what are you writing? And he told me this last year, too. He's like, I have a really hard time writing this number. He can't write five in English, so he was practicing that with himself right now, when I was translating this in English. He said, I have a hard time writing down five and four in English. These fives seem fine. I think I'm going to keep this.
我叔叔开始自己写字，我问他在写什么？他去年也告诉我这个。他说，我写这个数字太难了。他不会用英语写“5”，所以刚才我把它翻译成英语时，他在那里练习。他说，用英语写“5”和“4”很难。这些“5”看起来不错。我想我会留下这个。
The fan turned back on. So one more question I'm going to ask is, I think between the resistance and the Taliban times and everything, what was one of the hardest moments of his life? And he said, when one of our guys was shot on the road and died right there. I picked him up on my back. And it was bitter, bitter cold in the mountains.
风扇又转起来了。我要问的最后一个问题是，我认为在抵抗运动和塔利班时期以及这一切之间，他一生中最艰难的时刻是什么？他说，当我们的人在路上被枪杀并死在那里时。我把他背在背上。山上寒风凛冽。
And finally, he said, I managed to find a really small mosque in the middle of nowhere. He says, I went in there with him. And there was a really small bed. He said, I laid the dead body there. And I was laying on the floor next to him, trying to get an hour or two sleep, because it had been my third night without sleep. And boom, right there, a big hole in the ceiling cracked. Because it was hailing really bad. And he said soon the mosque started filling up. And it got to the point where it was up to my thighs.
最后，他说，我设法在荒郊野外找到了一座很小的清真寺。他说，我背着他进去。里面有一张很小的床。他说，我把尸体放在那里。我躺在旁边的地板上，想睡上一两个小时，因为那是我第三个没睡觉的夜晚。突然，天花板被击穿了一个大洞。因为当时冰雹下得太凶了。他说很快清真寺开始积水。水深到了我的大腿。
Eventually, I had to go. And I laid down next to the dead body. My clothes got bloodied, and I started to smell. But I had no choice. It was my third night without sleep. And he was a good friend of mine, he says. Same age. We were fighting and just hours ago, he was with me. He says that was his hardest day.
最终，我不得不离开。我躺在尸体旁边。我的衣服上沾满了血，开始发臭。但我没得选。那是我第三个没睡的夜晚。他是我很好的朋友，他说。同年纪。我们正在战斗，而就在几小时前，他还和我在一起。他说那是他最艰难的一天。
[WHISPERING] This is probably going to be my last recording. It's probably about 1:00 at night right now. I couldn't sleep tonight. It's because, I couldn't say anything at that time because, you know, it's my uncle, but that interview was so emotional. When I asked him what was the hardest part ever, of everything you've been through, he mentioned having to sleep next to his friend just hours after he was killed. And the hail pouring down on him, and him trembling in that cold.
[低语] 这可能是我的最后一次录音了。现在大概是凌晨1点。我今晚睡不着。是因为，我当时什么都没说，毕竟那是我叔叔，但那段采访太感人了。当我问他经历过的最艰难时刻是什么时，他提到了在朋友死后几个小时不得不睡在他身边。冰雹打在身上，他在严寒中颤抖。
One of the reasons I wanted to interview my uncle before I left was because I knew it was going to really have a lasting impression on me. And just in case I ever get soft, and I get like, you know, maybe I should just stay in America, or maybe, you know. That image of him having to do that will at least keep me going for another five years.
我想在离开前采访叔叔的原因之一，是我知道这会给我留下长久的印象。以防我变得脆弱，或者像说“也许我应该待在美国”之类的。他不得不那样做的画面，至少能支撑我再走过五年。
We have a really close relationship. I mean it's to the point where sometimes I accidentally call him dad. That's how close we are. And he really has high hopes for me. And he tells me all the time that he thinks I'm so smart, and that I'm going to do so much for this country. And, it's just, he's been through so much. I can't let all that just go in vain. I want him to see an Afghanistan moving forward. Because of anybody, he deserves to see it.
我们的关系真的很亲近。我的意思是，亲近到有时我口误叫他爸爸。我们就是这么亲。他对我有很高的期望。他一直告诉我，他觉得我很聪明，我能为这个国家做很多贡献。他经历过这么多。我不能让这些都白费。我希望他能看到一个向前的阿富汗。因为他比任何人都更有资格看到这一天。
And I can't even begin to explain how much respect and how much I admire him. Despite all he's been through, he's just about the nicest guy you'll ever meet. He still can't walk past a kitten, you know. That's incredible. To have that big of a heart. Because it does make you rough. And it does harden you. But this guy hasn't been hardened at all.
我无法用言语表达我对他有多么尊敬和钦佩。尽管经历了这么多，他依然是你见过最善良的人。他看到小猫仍然走不动道。太不可思议了。心能有这么宽。因为这种经历会让人变得粗糙。会让你冷酷。但他一点也没有变冷酷。
One of my dreams is somehow to get my uncle a visa, and take him on a trip to America. You know, take him to Vegas. That's one of the things. If anybody deserves to just lose himself for a weekend in Vegas, it's my uncle. To have some fun, to relax. Hopefully, by next year I'll be able to take him. Despite everything, I'm going to be pulled back here, I know it. I just can't-- I just can't do it any other way. I can't let my uncle down.
我的梦想之一是设法给叔叔弄到签证，带他去美国旅行。带他去拉斯维加斯。那是其中之一。如果有人值得在拉斯维加斯度过一个周末来放松自己，那就是我叔叔。去玩玩，放松一下。希望明年我能带他去。尽管如此，我知道我还会被拉回这里。我无法用其他方式。我不能让叔叔失望。
Hyder Akbar. He's now 20 years old, a junior at Yale University. His recordings were produced for radio by Susan Burton, with funding from the Corporation for Public Broadcasting. Susan and Hyder have also just published a book, based in part on the two radio documentaries they did for our program. It's called, Come Back to Afghanistan. It's funny, it's charming, it is unnerving and eye-opening and completely unlike anything else on the subject.
海德尔·阿克巴尔。他现在20岁，耶鲁大学大三学生。他的录音由苏珊·伯顿为电台制作，由公共广播公司提供资金。苏珊和海德尔也刚刚出版了一本书，部分基于他们为我们的节目制作的两部广播纪录片。书名叫《回到阿富汗》。它有趣、迷人、令人不安、发人深省，并且与这个主题的其他任何作品都完全不同。
One footnote to Hyder's story. About six months after we first broadcast today's program, back in 2003, that man that Hyder took to be interrogated, Abdul Wali, the one who died while being interrogated by US forces, he became international news. It turns out the US government concluded that he may not have died of a heart attack, as Hyder was told.
关于海德尔故事的一个脚注。在我们在2003年第一次播出今天这期节目的六个月后，那个被海德尔带去审讯的男人，阿卜杜勒·瓦利，那个在美军审讯期间死去的人，成为了国际新闻。事实证明，美国政府得出的结论是，他可能并非死于心脏病，正如海德尔被告知的那样。
The American, who Hyder refers to as Dave in the story, was in fact a CIA contractor named David Passaro, and was indicted by the US Justice Department on charges of assault in the case. Passaro allegedly beat Wali with a large flashlight. He claims his innocence. Pictures of Abdul Wali's corpse showed bruises on his back that Hyder and his dad never saw.
海德尔在故事中称之为戴夫的那名美国人，实际上是一名名叫戴维·帕萨罗的中情局承包商，并被美国司法部以袭击罪起诉。据称帕萨罗用一个大号手电筒殴打了瓦利。他坚称自己无罪。阿卜杜勒·瓦利尸体的照片显示他的后背有海德尔和他父亲从未见过的淤青。
Passaro's trial is scheduled to begin in federal court in Raleigh, North Carolina, in December. He is the first civilian charged with prisoner abuse in Afghanistan and Iraq. Three members of the 82nd Airborne saw the whole thing and are reportedly willing to testify against Passaro. Hyder's been told that he might be called to testify as well. In March of this past year, the military said that its own investigations indicated that 26 prisoners have died of criminal homicide while in US captivity, including Abdul Wali.
帕萨罗的审判定于12月在北卡罗来纳州罗利的联邦法院开始。他是首位在阿富汗和伊拉克被指控虐囚的平民。第82空降师的三名成员目睹了整个过程，并据报道愿意出庭指控帕萨罗。海德尔被告知他可能也会被传唤作证。在去年三月，军方表示他们自己的调查表明，26名囚犯在美军监禁期间死于刑事谋杀，其中包括阿卜杜勒·瓦利。
Special thanks today to Hyder's parents and brother, Nadera Akbar, Said Fazel Akbar, and Omar Akbar. And to Sartore, and his uncle Rauf. Also thanks to [? Dmitry Shub. ?] Our website, www.thisamericanlife.org, where you can listen to the first of the two documentaries that Hyder did for our program a few years back. Or to this show, or to any of our shows, for absolutely free. Or you can buy CDs. Or you know you can download today's program in our archives at audible.com/thisamericanlife.
今天特别感谢海德尔的父母和兄弟：纳德拉·阿克巴尔、赛义德·法泽尔·阿克巴尔和奥马尔·阿克巴尔。感谢萨托雷和他的叔叔劳夫。也感谢[无法辨音]。我们的网站 www.thisamericanlife.org，你可以在那里免费收听海德尔几年前为我们的节目制作的两部纪录片中的第一部。或者收听本期节目，或我们的任何节目，完全免费。或者你可以购买CD。或者你可以在 audible.com/thisamericanlife 的档案中下载今天的节目。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[赞助商名单]
WBEZ management oversight for our program by Mr. Torey Malatia, who explains why it is so hard getting objective journalism on to the public radio station that he manages.
WBEZ对我们节目的管理监管，由托里·马拉蒂亚先生负责。他解释了为什么在他管理的公共广播电台上进行客观报道如此困难。
Professional people here are the communists that were trained by the Russians.
这里的专业人士是受过俄国人训练的共产主义者。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。